Vsauce Kevin here high-heeled shoes were
invented by Persian horse riders to help
hold their feet in stirrups which
allowed them to stand up to shoot their
bows and arrows nobility in Western
Europe adopted the style as a symbol of
machismo and the higher the heels you
wore the wealthier you appeared because
they were so impractical for walking on
cobbled streets in the 1670s the
diminutive king louis xiv loved how high
heels made him taller and he ordered
that only members of his court could Don
his trademark red heels women began to
adopt masculine fashion including the
high heel but by the 1740s men's fashion
became more practical and less
ostentatious and high heels were
considered foolish it wasn't until the
mid 19th century that high heels on
women symbolized female sexuality
largely due to their use and
pornographic postcards while neckties
date back to at least 210 BC China they
were worn by the statues of Qin Shih
Huang's terracotta army there's no
evidence to suggest that neckties were
commonly worn by men at that time the
modern necktie evolved from the cravat
worn by 17th century Croatian soldiers
with theories on their use being to hide
a dirty shirt to provide psychological
protection of the neck during battle to
hold together their jackets or to
distinguish themselves from other
soldiers during the 30 Years War in the
early 1600s Croatian mercenaries were
hired by Frances King Louie the 8th and
Parisians loved their colorful knotted
neckerchiefs with the word cravat coming
from a corrupt French pronunciation of
Croat by the early 19th century the way
a man knot in his neck wear became such
an important indication of his style
that the cravat became known more simply
as a tie and it served to separate class
as you can't wear one while operating
machinery and it gets in the way of
manual labor the necktie is also a
phallic symbol that points directly to a
man's codpiece a triangular cloth
covering a man's groin primary
in 15th and 16th century Europe men's
hoes at that time were open at the
crotch with the doublet a tight-fitting
jacket extending to the hips as
basically the only thing between the
world and their manhood as doublets
became fashionably shorter the codpiece
was needed to cover the area but it
eventually evolved from simple
concealment to fanciful embellishment
with King Henry the eighth of England
famously sporting a massive codpiece not
only did it emphasize his regal bits but
it may have also held medicine to
relieve symptoms associated with
syphilis the codpiece craze came to a
close when Queen Elizabeth the first
dictated that men's fashion become more
feminized by the end of her reign in
1603 it was replaced by a vertical
opening concealed in folds of material
that evolved into something today you
may refer to as a fly and as always
thanks for watching
you